if we do this
we'd be going in short-handed yeah you
mean because it killed all our friends
we owe this to everyone who's not in
this room to try
[Music]
it's not about how much we lost it's
about how much we have left
[Music]
we're the avengers we gotta finish this
you trust me i do
you could not live with your own failure
[Music]
where did that bring you
back to me
tickets on sale now hi everyone it's
charlie we got a brand new avengers
in-game trailer to break down
tickets are on sale that's why they
dropped this there's a whole bunch of
new footage it's from all over the place
and they're mixing and matching so many
different things so you probably noticed
a bunch of easter eggs during this
because tickets are on sale we'll do a
new round of the imax giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
trailer on the video
we start on a shot of the avengers bass
at night there's a whole bunch of voice
over from a bunch of the different
avengers
banner starts with if we do this we go
in short-handed
i think this is happening relatively
early in the movie before you see them
all climb on the benatar with captain
marvel there
there was footage that disney screened
at a private investors meeting that
takes place directly after the captain
marvel post credit scene where you have
thor grabbing stormbreaker trying to
shake captain marvel a little bit just
testing her
the footage is basically captain marvel
showing up in her gold costume
then later after she explains who she is
she's one of the first people to push
that they go
directly for thanos and because at that
point nebula and iron man have already
made it back to planet earth they have
the benetar available
they use information that nebula gives
them about where thanos's farm is to go
directly after him so that's what
they're doing on the back of the benatar
here where captain america is wearing
his winter soldier outfit but like
banner says they're going in
short-handed because hulk
is not there banner himself isn't on the
back of the benatar here
iron man isn't there and they don't have
ant-man either fun fact too
rhody is also one of the first people to
question captain marvel about
why she wasn't around for the early
avengers engagements how come you
weren't here for the snap where were you
this whole time
people wonder you know like how come
nick fury didn't page her before now
love the scene of thor here at the table
imply that this is happening when
they're all arguing initially he has
that giant plate of what looks like
dinner rolls in a lacroix
so thor is a big fan of lacroix if you
ever get to have dinner with him
whether or not you're a big fan of that
behind the scenes that's what they drink
on set when they're having lunch this is
a picture of them behind the scenes with
doctor strange filming infinity war with
everybody drinking lacroix
there's the black widow dialogue they
transposed with this scene of her with
her long red hair sitting outside the
avengers base in the rain
saying we owe this to everyone in this
room who's not here to try
but here's the thing she doesn't have
red hair when she's on the back of the
benatar
so using her hair to chart the timeline
a little bit when it's blonde and short
relatively soon after the events of the
snap maybe several weeks maybe a couple
months not that much time has passed
because captain america still has a
beard in the captain marvel post credits
scene
so maybe this scene of him here in the
bathroom clean shaven is when he
actually shaves the beard off relatively
early in the film
now we know when the scene from the
other trailer with him talking to black
widow
on the back of the benatar is coming
from is from really early in the film
when they first go after thanos which as
you can assume now is probably pretty
unsuccessful like they have a shot that
they transpose of them
looking up as if they're looking up at a
ship then you see thanos's sanctuary two
ship above that planet it's really hard
to tell when this is happening during
the movie though
and this planet behind the benatar when
you see them flying before they flash
the interior of the ship
is not planet earth it's a good reminder
that they're mixing and matching footage
from all over the timeline of the film
so none of these shots happen one right
after the other
they splice in the footage of the
quinjet over tokyo this is probably when
black widow goes to get hawkeye we see
him later in the trailer but i think
that corresponds to the scene with all
the original
avengers together without thor and
captain marvel also fun fact that at no
point during this trailer do you see
all six original avengers on screen
together but really interesting there
are a couple different scenes with
different combinations of the original
avengers together even the one where
they find thanos at the end of the
trailer here
you get the iron man voiceover where
he's hugging pepper says it's not about
what we lost is about how much we have
left
obviously the dialogue is from a
different part in the film like i said
the stormbreaker scene happens from
really early in the film when captain
marvel is pushing for them to go after
thanos the first time that they go after
thanos during the movie it's implied
that they fight him a couple different
times during the film
because it looks like he comes to the
avengers base at the end of this trailer
you get a wide shot of the avengers base
in the middle of the daytime but then
you see iron man in his brand new armor
with the gold arms his classic comic
book inspired armor flying over new york
city from what looks like much later in
the film
the way they cut this it makes it seem
like black widow with her longer red
hair is smiling at hawkeye it is
possible that this is after they bring
him back because we see her with long
hair when she goes to tokyo
because i think that was the whole idea
of his scenes from the last trailer is
that like he's high-fiving his daughter
there teaching her archery with them
having a picnic
on their farm in the background he has
the ankle bracelet on so you know it's
before the snap so not only has he gone
full ronin he's got that giant skull
tattoo on his arm to remind him of his
dead family
you get the scene of iron man and
captain america in the alleyway do you
trust me
this is happening somewhere in new york
city later in the film captain america
is wearing his newer
scale armor he has an earpiece in
captain america says
yes i think that that dialogue comes
from that same scene but the footage of
iron man
shaking his hand i think is actually him
shaking ant-man's
hand because look at the bottom of his
costume here on the right side of the
frame
none of captain america's armors look
like that not the new scale armor not in
his classic armor from the avengers film
not the winter soldier armor this looks
like ant-man's new costume because he
has that silver belt on so this might be
from that scene where they're looking at
the events of the original avengers
movie i just don't think that they
wanted to show you
ant-man full in frame but i do think
that he's shaking ant-man's hand in this
scene
you get that really funny and sad
picture of iron man looking at
spider-man's picture with them both
giving each other bunny ears looking in
the camera he has a little plaque that
he's holding upside down in frame that
might be his certificate for joining the
special stark program
i think this is left over from civil war
i think that was the excuse that they
used so that aunt may would give him
permission to go to germany for the
little quote-unquote field trip
this picture of iron man here too
reminds me a lot of the original
avengers movie like he has the line of
dialogue where he says we're the
avengers we gotta finish this
but i think that they spliced that
sentence together from two different
parts of the film
so remember two important quotes from
iron man we're the avengers
we could bust arms dealers all live long
day but that up there
that's end game is the quote from
avengers age of ultron
then there's the quote from the original
avengers movie where he's making the
drink talking to loki and says
if we can't protect the earth you'll be
damn sure we'll avenge it
so now they are in that timeline they're
damn sure going to avenge the earth
this shot of thor inside this wooden hut
might actually be from
thanos's hut on his little farm there
where he sat down at the end of infinity
war the planet is called titan 2 but
it's made to be a new version of what
titan used to look like before it was
destroyed
this might be from earlier in the film
when they first go after him this shot
of rocket though looking up at something
looks like it's actually on thanos's
ship though because look at all those
carvings on the floor there
those look like the designs on thanos
big ship which is called the sanctuary
2. we saw a little bit of it when thanos
took gamora back there to
get the location of the soul gem from
her this shot of captain america with
his shield is in his new scale armor i
think pretty much
all these next couple of shots are from
the same scene
at the avengers base when thanos pours
in so at some point he comes to attack
the avengers facility
which i also think corresponds to the
scene of ant-man in the last trailer
where you see him really small you see
like the rubble of this big explosion
like a pencil all these office supplies
i think that's after thanos comes and
destroys the avengers base
you get the thanos voice over you could
not live with your own failure and where
did that bring you
back to me that line of dialogue might
be from earlier in the film when they
first go to fight him on his
farm so i think the idea is is that
there's a couple encounters with him
a couple different times they're
short-handed like banner says
in each of those times they're
unsuccessful they probably don't finally
beat him at the end of the film until
all original six avengers are working
together at the same time
everybody at once style you see
important to planet earth with heavily
damaged armor as if he's been fighting
them earlier in the film this may be
damage that they just dealt him when
they tried to fight him earlier
you see iron man and his gold armor that
looks like it was damaged a little bit
in the explosion
then you see the original avengers are
some of the original avengers
slowly walking to thanos in the rubble
who's just sitting there you see his
giant
sword stuck in the ground even though
you only see iron man captain america
and thor
walking towards him in frame remember in
the last trailer we also saw scenes of
nebula
amidst the same type of rebels which
seems like it's also happening at the
avengers base
and we saw a rocket standing on war
machine that also seemed like it was
from a similar scene so there are more
people besides these three original
avengers in this moment here
remember the scene of hawkeye in those
tunnels underneath a building with a
giant explosion going off in the last
trailer
that could also be from when thanos
blows up the avengers base
and also you know big hulk theory so
when is banner gonna finally turn into
the hulk again
because there are a couple different
shots where they're walking through the
avengers base like where they're wearing
the white quantum
suits banner is not in this one but this
shot of them from the other trailer
they're not wearing those suits so it's
from a different point in the film
banner is in the background of this but
it's just
banner he hasn't become the hulk yet so
early theory about the timeline of the
film and when we finally get
hulk again because i know we're all
wondering about professor hulk we've
seen a couple different
models from him wearing different types
of suits one in the quantum suit because
of all the toys
but one in this purple looking spandex
suit that expands with him when he hulks
out
so early theory banner does not turn
back into the hulk again
until thanos blows up the avengers base
and that's what triggers his first big
transformation that would also imply
that this fight at the avengers base is
happening a little bit earlier in the
film because i think they're trying to
do everything they can
to keep footage from the very end of the
film out of this very rarely do we ever
see scenes from the very end or if we do
they're heavily doctored so that we
don't know
that's what's going on even if you look
at the old infinity war trailers where
you see captain america grabbing his
gauntlet that's from a little bit later
in infinity war but there was still a
lot of film that happened after this
moment because that was the gauntlet
that was before he assembled all the
gems that was before he snapped everyone
before you got all those other scenes
so unless there's some crazy photoshop
skills going on here it seems like
they wear the white quantum suits and
work out this plot before
thanos attacks the avengers base because
there wouldn't be any base for them to
walk through if it was all blown up
interesting things that we know are in
the film but have not seen yet because
of all those recent posters they
released we know that valkyrie is going
to be in the movie at some point i have
a feeling that you know because we don't
see thor
in this giant scene with all the
avengers together he might be traveling
around the nine realms looking to
assemble a small army to get some help
for them in their fight against thanos
and during that maybe that's when he
runs into valkyrie because the ruse was
revealed that she and korg helped
part of the asgardians escape thor's
ship before thanos showed up at the
beginning of infinity war
we haven't seen wong in any of the
trailers we know that he's in the film
we haven't seen okoye in any of the
trailers we know that she's in the film
too so we know that they go to wakanda
at some point
i'm assuming wong also provides some
input into what doctor strange may have
meant when he said this is the only way
because at some point they will have to
address the 1 in 14 million chance that
doctor strange said that they had what
was that one timeline that he saw where
they were able to win
but the russos did confirm that the
movie is going to be crazy long
now people at disney have said that the
run time might come down just like a
little bit because people reported that
it was going to be over three hours
which is crazy long
think about how many moments you have
with the characters in a movie that long
i know it doesn't seem too much longer
than say like captain america civil war
which is just a little over two and a
half hours
but an extra 30 minutes in a film is a
lot of extra time i would recommend
that you do not buy the large soda just
maybe don't buy drinks at all when you
go see this film just to be safe
but i think just based on what all the
official people have been saying the
last couple of days is that when you sit
through the entire credits like
everything in the movie then it will be
over three hours long i know there are a
lot of questions about what the
post-credits scenes are we'll talk more
about that as we get more evidence but i
have a couple theories about them
teasing phase four stuff i've done
videos for that already i'll link one of
them at the end of this
but just post all your theories in the
comments and if you spotted any big
easter eggs that i didn't mention in the
video just let me know in the comments
there was another new game of thrones
trailer that dropped this morning i'll
do a video for that next i'll try to get
that up in the next couple of hours but
leave all your requests in the comments
and i'll name a giveaway winner when
i post new marvel click here for that
marvel phase 4 video and post credit
scenes that i talk about and click here
for those brand new game of thrones
trailers
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you